何故っていうのは斜めっていうのは知らない三脚がないのでこれで踊っています
はいこんにちははじめ社長です
えええ
何が話せばいいのか以前以前というか結構最近なんですけども動画で176万円の財布
を買ったのを覚えていますでしょうか
今も大事に使っているんですけどもこちらの財布176万円のシャネルとアリゲーター
の方が使っている財布でございますあり方や
でさぞお話をしましょうはなぜ私
がこの財布を手に入れられたのかという話をしますと去年のいうフェスルーバー
グランプリっていう大会がありまして
でそこで私はありがたくあの優勝させていただきまして優勝の賞金1000万円
1000万円を使って100万円ぐらいの値段がかかるちょっとビッグな企画を10発
やろうという話になり
いまして色々やっぱり100万円となると何ができるかっていうのを考えてちょっと
時間がかかったりもしたんですけども
100万円企画を岩盤とか間に合ったりして無事
ここまでやってきたんですけどもそのラスト一発が100枚の西方冠王と思ったら
オーバーして176万円になってしまって計9本の
100万円企画で動画が終わってしまっ
ん
ダイハツだったんですよここで事件が発生してしまいました柚庵グランプリの商品の
1000万円
この1戦前実は
使い道が決まっておりまして動画の制作費用1千万円分ということでございます
私は胸に手を当てて聞いてみました100万円近く今までやってきてつで何か一個だけ
キャラてほしいのあるんじゃねそうください嘘と
違うんじゃねーから帰っていい
何でもいいな動画になれば何でもいいなみたいなとかあったんで琉球カードまぎり
セーフみたいな別にあれ使って遊ぶわけじゃないし買ってみて実物を見てったってゆう
ちゃんと動画になってるしねあの日目がいい気もねーなー髪の毛で泳げたり行為れる
できたん誰もがんありつかなと
バンディジャンプやりまくるのもなんか言えしかし切ってできてあれもなか堂になっ
てれば ok かなと客ないけどいる
出てきたんですけど全部とりあえずなんとか動画制作費っぽい完全使ってきたんです
けども
これは違ったみたいですはい財布276万円使うのはあの動画にはなってますよ
もちろんあの僕もその通りでやりました稼働にはなったしその100万円176万に
なっちゃったんですけども100万円の財布を買うっていう動画の製作記
なってるんで ok なと思ったんですけどもちゃんとか
にしないままこれをラーって買った後に俺はさすがに動画制作と言わないんじゃないか
ということになりまして
ni
ああああああ
チェーン笑いよりわー
動画 a 先だったら全然面白いんじゃいうか賞金276万円ねこれが手に入るんだっ
たらもがありかなと思ったんですけど
[音楽]
ず腹で今のところとりあえず今てその賞金にやっぱ無理ってだってあの
自腹で自分のお金の176万円でこの財宝
買っております
[音楽]
助けてくださいあげるだと良いの皆さん嬉しい
まずまず嬉しいお知らせですこの財布を買うために使った約200万円は
a まだ残っておりますこれ自腹で買ったってまだ200万円残ってるので
赤間駅各後2回できそうでございますお願いがございます
それに伴いこの財布僕の本当に俺の貯金してきた直径してきたを guerrero
えええええええズラ
[ __ ]姉だったホットで flies よわかるコンディションの商品だったと思った
ものがまだのず腹ですよ
つらっばすぐに寝財布はねちょっとやり過ぎたとこれは動画制作気にはなりませんどう
見てもあのシティ切りを自分のお金を入れるものとして使っているんで
動画に映っているものの違うぞということになってあの今自分で100がまず6も
エッグ
取材不可ってこっつんだっ
ぶーちゃーん
という気で早速品財布を売りに行こうと思いますへ
何でかってそりゃそうでしょ自分の腹で176万な魚で買わないでしょ本当にこんな
ああああああああ
全然いいんですけどあの僕そんな直近4削ってまで176万円の財布を買うかって言わ
れるとかはないんで高級ブランド品を取り扱っているお店にいって打ってきます
内になると思います次にあの今回の動画はまあ簡単に説明しますと彫金で手に入れられ
たと思っていた財布が実は賞金が使えなかったよってことで自腹になってしまって
176万円を失った肇社長が
財布276万円なんて使うわけねーだろと逆ギレ c
それを売りに行って形でな絵になるのか
という動画でございまーす本拠207ぜいやもう
100円の債務でいい短い期間だったんですけどもあの176万円したよっ使わせて
いただいて本当に幸せでしたというわけで自腹で失われて176万円がない
帰ってくるのか早速回答書って言ってこれ止めますと骨無傷というかも完璧な状態なん
で
[音楽]
ブーバーし
いる
ウサインかをとっています出会いかー
はい
ません
ああああああ
麗水します水お願いしまーすと本日は東京
ブーブーちょっとすっ
確かに状態すごいんですね
[音楽]
船ブランドもうず買おう
お金なのリンクの全く買わないですね
今回はそれがあっいいっていう嘘
感じです
me
ブーバーし
ないいうえそうなんですねぇー
水までスネアの知る限りらの頑張らさせていただいて額の方が実際
いろいろありがとうございませんああああああなるほど a
[音楽]
なあやっぱり当地の厨房っていう風ならつけられてしまうとあの下がってしまうんです
けれども
あのそれでも拠点がきれず離このできるかいい
頑張らせていただきたい
こういう感じが使えそうですねあの保存
me
逆にそのまあ新しいものであればいいというものではこの5君ですねやっぱり
逆に今はちょっと使って狩りするなら育ってからってなるとやっぱりどうしても金額が
をしてしまう商品もある目先の腰痛3番か
[音楽]
us のジャック関する感覚ん
me
telas
いやいやー2
2へと思うん
やっぱり私としましてはやっぱりすごい
いいんだものでもありますしあの綺麗なお品物と周りもあるのでやっぱり欲しい商品は
あるんですけどまぁそういうちょっとお願い生きるかいいかんってやつあるんです
けれどもっていい結果よ母姿勢
まあ今で買い取るに来たんですけど
値段が43本ですね
ございましたはい
はいありがとうございますちょうだい件はい失礼します
ブーブー言いいく
的に odg まではなさいさせておいたら皆さんありがとうございます
あとやっぱり西尾でありまえんまあ通れ
ですね
切れましたん
芝せっかくさてまでしていただいたんですよいっ
持ち帰りますちゃいます疲れました使い魔そういうねうーん
与儀志望の企業抜けがございましたカス
いや
なんか特になかったんですけど買った金額と売れないのですね
たくさんず大きくからって言うねそう人ぐらいにあればもうそれで使ったほうが綺麗
だったするなぁいいのかなっていう
僕の判断です
[音楽]
ん
うんん
r
me
pa ん
本所恐れてるそれ僕の全くないよ見た方がいい